the tide appears to have turned for
Michael avenatti the lawyer who
attempted to take president Trump the
court had now faced decades in prison
after a jury here in New York found him
guilty of trying to extort millions of
dollars from the Nike sports company
chip Reid reports
Michael avenatti rocketed to fame two
years ago as the attorney for porn star
stormy Daniels in her lawsuits against
President Trump but his meteoric rise
was matched only by the speed of his
catastrophic fall a jury found him
guilty of attempting to extort millions
of dollars from Nike by threatening to
go public with claims that the shoe
company was illegally paying high school
basketball players Nike denied that
claim and said the verdict speaks
volumes he's in a bit of a state of
shock a vanadis attorneys say he plans
to appeal a vanadis avenatti
and he's a strong guy and obviously he's
disappointed but he's a fighter avenatti
used his fame as Daniel's attorney to
dominate the spotlight as he excoriated
President Trump for allegedly having an
affair with Daniel's and then paying her
to cover it up but for the fact that
he's president he would be indicted on
numerous criminal charges he even
suggested he might run for president but
now it's avenatti who faces numerous
criminal charges in addition to the
guilty verdicts for which he could get
more than 40 years he is accused of
defrauding Daniels in a book deal and
defrauding other clients of millions of
dollars avenatti has been held behind
bars since January for violating his
bail conditions his attorneys say he's
reportedly in the same solitary
confinement cell that held Mexican drug
lord el chapo they say he's being
treated quote like a caged animal for
CBS this morning Saturday chip read
Washington
you